[Musique]
de brillantes de très cultivé faire et
très gentil magnifique respire
l'harmonie dans le chou-fleur original
fait qu'on est multi cas des adjectifs à
foison pour parler de jean-pierre la
selve musiciens et nos musicologue ses
amis ont voulu lui rendre un dernier
hommage au jardin de l'état
les artistes connus et d'autres -
partagent un pique nique en musique une
tradition simple et logique pour
beaucoup d'artistes c'est l'admiré
beaucoup
c'est quelqu'un qui parlait beaucoup de
gens qui parlent cette langue était
antoine une fois ensemble droite et aux
états unis
on va dans les landes était là bas
heureusement qu'il était là présent
croisement j'ai vu quand même la mise et
elle et ça m'a vraiment semblent bonnes
femmes la paix trouvent leur mariage
l'apaba dinars ces bâtisses folio la
rigueur est des gens bien être et
musiques traditionnelles de la région et
c'est un document extrêmement important
dans la mesure où il a su rassembler
toutes les chansons créharer de la
réunion
il a également rassemblé les éléments
magiques on va si bien que la réunion de
maurice de madagascar du sous sol ça me
donne tout ce qui est fait en matière de
musique à la et les t1 ethnomusicologue
c'est à dire que il s'intéressait à tout
ce qui était ethnographie c'est ainsi
qu'ils m'avaient invité là je suis
entendu cadre musical
il m'a mis d'inviter à une soutenance de
thèse à sa soutenance de thèse
il l'a soutenu la thèse sur des bassins
suivants ripolin panon des bassins ce
gros blanc qui était le mari de madame
desbassyns et il a fait une thèse
absolument brillante un homme cultivé
curieux et joyeux voilà comment les amis
de jean-pierre la selve et le décrit il
fallait le connaître il avait été en
haut il était en bas mais il avait la
mélodie de la vie en lui qu'en soient
les dents dans son petit lit son ange
gardien y veille 6 mai sont vraiment les
côtés robert salis
ma
dont il n'a pas à la musique fast
génération en génération dans l'île et
souvent c'est ce qu'on croit démodé il
revient à la mode il ya il faut des gens
bien c'est mou bien les pattes jaunes
par exemple combien le groupe de
bernadette ladauge ça n'a pas d'âge
apparaissant enrichi la mémoire est une
agence intervient porté par
l'association folklorique de la réunion
ce regroupement dans un jardin de l'état
mise à disposition par le département a
permis à beaucoup de chasse et la
tristesse de quelqu'un qu'il ne faut pas
oublier je suis très content du moment
je pense que jean pierre
s'il veut nous voir c'est vraiment des
moments comme il les aimait c'est
convivial et musical c'est la bonne
franquette on rentre on sent quand on
veut c'est le coeur qui colle
ces artistes bâtisseur d'une partie de
notre patrimoine pourront être oublié
car chacune des pierres à son rôle dans
l'édifice culturel réunionnais
[Musique]